I'm Rebecca Ritter's welcome to the
program Russian forces have carried out
multiple airstrikes on a military
training ground near Lev in Western
Ukraine killing at least 35 people and
injuring many more the assault brings
the wall closer to the border with
Poland and threatens the relative safety
of leviv where many ukrainians have fled
since the invasion began in Kiev the
mayor is telling residents to prepare to
fight as Russia's military attacks
civilian targets nearby
fire Crews rushed to the scene after a
mortar struck an apartment building on
the outskirts of Kiev
the artillery shelling started at around
6 30 in the morning oh she's
around there are people living in these
apartment buildings civilians this is a
suburban area here
with Russia stepping up its bombardment
of Ukrainian cities including the
capital it's feared more and more
civilians will be caught in the
crossfire
satellite images show Russian forces
just 25 kilometers from Central Kiev
president Valore Demir zelensky has
promised ukrainians will put up a stiff
fight in what he's calling a war for the
country's Independence
we have no right to let up in the
intensity of our defense
no matter how difficult it is
we have no right to let up in the force
of our resistance the enemy is bringing
more columns into Ukrainian territory
the besieged port city of mariupo
continues to Bear the full brunt of
Russia's bombardment
the humanitarian situation is worsening
by the hour for hundreds of thousands
trapped without power running water or
fresh food
in the nearby southern city of malito
pole which has already been taken by
Russian forces residents turned out to
protest against the alleged kidnapping
of their mayor and to demand his release
as fighting rages people in and around
Kiev will be hoping and praying that
last minute diplomacy could still spare
them the worst of what has happened to
other Ukrainian cities
and DW's Maintenance building is
standing by for us in Kiev Matthias
Fierce fighting on the outskirts of the
city now how is the situation there
today
it's the same as yesterday the day
before yesterday and all the other days
before almost since the beginning of the
war there's fighting and on the
outskirts uh ceasefires and fighting
fires and
fighting and ceasefires and the Russian
troops are regrouping but they're not
yet advancing on the city most people
have left the city and uh are waiting or
have fled the city and are waiting
outside those who are left are trying to
stay at home as much as possible there
are roadblocks
etc etc it's uh pretty much like it has
been for at least a week all right well
let's take a look out overnight uh
Russia escalated attacks in the west of
the country firing several missiles at a
military base near leviv or more can you
tell us about that attack
foreign
yeah there is there is some important
military infrastructure in leaf and um
there has be have been bombs falling in
that area before or Rockets rather
hitting that area before but
um it has stayed relatively calm after
the first days of the war there and now
in a new round of attacks on strategic
uh goals Russia has shelled this
military Air Base
um similar things have happened to other
cities that have been relatively uh
peaceful in the past few days from time
to time the Russians Target one of these
military airports or bases yesterday it
was an airport and an oil
stock like oil stocks near Kiev that had
been set on to fire so Russia is
continuing to
um
to Target the in Hinterland the Inland
with missiles and bombs
Ukraine says that there are humanitarian
corridors planned for civilians to be
able to flee on Sunday today and there's
a renewed attempt to reach the besiege
port of Mario pole has there been any
progress on either of those things
well these corridors they seem to work
from time to time on a smaller scale but
some of the worst hit cities asthma yupo
have not yet been able to establish
these corridors the people there have
been cut off from supplies and medical
supplies food also infrastructure is
destroyed so there's a shortage of water
electricity is down for more than 10
days now and I don't know whether this
is going to happen today it's failed
every day they try every day they the
Russians promise to open the corridor
and then for some reason it collapses
there's shelling the the the the buses
with Metal Goods that try to get into
the city are are shelled or this or on
it can't even leave so
um I try to be optimistic but I it's
hard to believe that today it will work
president zielinski in his latest
address to the nation accused Russia of
creating what he calls
pseudo-republics in Ukraine what does he
mean by that
well there have been news that Russia is
planning to do a referendum on a
republic in this is the only major city
that is controlled by the Russians and
these republics would be modeled on the
two republics in Donetsk and luhansk
that Russians have established in 2014
that means they would declare their
autonomy or their independence and they
would establish a rule most likely a
military rule or or some kind of
dictatorship like they have
Russia would most probably recognize
them and they would split off the
territory because the Russian narrative
is that Ukraine is not United and that
uh that the local people in the local in
the russian-speaking regions are unhappy
with being part of Ukraine and seeking
autonomy this is not the case we have
seen demonstrations against Russian
occupiers in Herson despite the risk and
despite people having been arrested on
these demonstrations and as I'm hearing
now we are also seeing again
demonstrations against these plans for a
referendum so a significant part of the
population is completely against these
Russian occupiers but for the Russian
justification of the war this narrative
is of course crucial and they're going
to push it through it looks like
all right Matthias thank you for that
update DW correspondent Matthias
billinger in Kiev
last weekend in Kiev alone more than 80
babies were born in bomb shelters the
war is literally forcing expectant
mothers and their newborns underground
and into improvised maternity units
Matthias who he just spoke to there
visited one such unit in the Ukrainian
capital
it's the first time that Maxim is seeing
daylight the boy was born a day earlier
in the basement of kiev's maternity
hospital number five his mother Natalia
made sure to arrive at the hospital
early so good
because
When The War Began the ambulances
stopped running staying at home was
frightening we don't own a car and there
are no ambulances you don't know where
to flee and what to do
here I am fine the nurses and doctors
are next to me and can help me
since the beginning of the war the
nurses and doctors have tried to make
the clinic safe for wartime
patients spent entire nights in the
basements many children have been born
in these improvised shelters
this is our emergency room here's the
reanimation bed for newborn babies and
after operations and difficult births
they remain here under observation by
doctors we can deliver babies and do
operations here and keep patients who
need intensive care
right now it is calm and many patients
have been moved upstairs but often it's
easier for them to remain downstairs
just last night there were four Airaid
alarms where people had to go down to
the basement and come up after and some
of them had just an hour's break in
between
news of babies born in basements has
touched many here in Ukraine says the
clinics director
people come and bring bread and sweets
they don't even say who it's from they
just come and leave it at the security
post for our employees the doctors and
those who take care of the young mothers
I think people who behave like this
cannot be subdued
some patients have gone through quite an
ordeal Alina fled from one of caves and
battled suburbs just before her daughter
was born
I feel fine now but when I hear planes
flying I get nervous
we have all seen the images of the bond
maternity hospital in mariupo after
seeing those images I have been
nervously listening to whether Air Raid
Sirens are going off or not there's
nothing I can do about it
given the circumstances of her birth
Alina expects her daughter to be a tough
girl
look at some other developments in the
conflict France says Russian President
Vladimir Putin is not willing to end the
war in Ukraine French president Emmanuel
McCall and German Chancellor Olaf
Schultz held joint telephone talks with
Putin on Saturday the two Western
leaders urged Putin to agree to an
immediate ceasefire in Ukraine and find
a diplomatic solution
U.S President Joe Biden has authorized a
further 200 million in new weapons to
Ukraine in addition to the 350 million
at his already authorized for military
equipment it's the largest such package
in U.S history the move follows a raft
of sanctions from Washington including a
ban on Russian vodka
Italian police have seized a yacht worth
530 million euros owned by Russian
oligarch Andre palnachenko malnachenko
excuse me in the port of Trieste the
billionaire was sanctioned in response
to the Russia invasion of Ukraine last
week Italian police seized several
Villas and Yachts from five Russians on
the eu's sanctions list
the U.N says more than two and a half
million people have now fled Ukraine
more than half of them have crossed into
neighboring Poland now authorities in
several cities there say they're running
out of space at the border shelters have
sprung up to accommodate people arriving
exhausted after Days on the Road they're
mostly staffed by volunteers offering
what little Comfort they can
children find moments of joy in a
playful fight with Polish volunteers
aren't getting a lollipop
[Music]
but for their mothers and everyone else
it is a reality far too difficult to
ignore
use tanks to attack my grandmother's
house we pray to God to grant us a safe
passage
it was very scary when the bombs hit our
towns directly We Lost Light electricity
and water
this one and at five in the morning the
bombs were falling again right in the
center of the city they killed people
the bombs killed 21 people including
three children I have nightmares when I
think about it
in the small border Village of mediku
Polish volunteers are doing what they
can to support displaced families
they provide shelter blankets warm food
water exactly well and often just human
comfort
[Music]
Ukraine has thanked Poland for its help
we are really very very grateful to the
Polish people for such strong support of
Ukraine
it's also very important to the people
who stayed behind in Ukraine who are
continuing this fight and will fight
until Victory and also for those who
come to Poland and need help and human
warmth foreign
but the volunteers aren't just Polish
people are pouring in from different
parts of the world to lend a hand we're
operating 24 7. we don't stop the people
the refugees are coming from 50 yards
away mostly women and children old women
in a very sad State the UN estimates
that more than 2.5 million ukrainians
have fled and rushed to get to
neighboring countries
Poland is bearing the brunt of it
leaving it close to being overwhelmed
meanwhile the refugees do what they can
to keep their children distracted
joining me now from chemical on the
Polish Ukrainian border is DW's biggest
an unprecedented movement of people more
than one and a half million refugees
have crossed into Poland alone how is
the country managing
judging from what we have experiencing
over the past days I would tell pretty
well
um I mean in the first days it was a
little bit chaotic for obvious reasons
but in the last day the help has been
much better organized people arriving
here at the station of chemical where we
are right now they are immediately
provided with all their needs like food
free SIM cards advice where to go and
then they are very fast placed on buses
and trains to relocate and to other
cities but still it's a huge challenge
for everybody who's involved and because
the aid is still depending very much on
volunteers the mayor told us one
thousand two hundred volunteers are only
here in premiership so
um also the the community is reaching
their limits
um just to give you an idea this this
little signal of chemical they have only
60 thousand citizens but they are
welcoming thirty thousand two fifty
thousand refugees every day
and more people are expected Brigitte
how are authorities preparing them
they're already sending alarm Bells
saying that they're nearly at capacity
how are authorities preparing for more
intake
I mean they are trying to ask the um the
government for more funding for more
help and also the volunteers try to to
stock up their forces we saw a lot of
signs at the border crossing Satan help
help us needed we're looking for
volunteers they use the social media to
get people here to to join in the relief
effort what sort of support is Poland
getting from other governments and from
the EU
I mean they they are asking especially
other governments to to Really uh get
get support in relocating the people
because the mayor told us here in
Premiere that is the thing which is most
important the problem here is that many
people who are arriving here just they
don't want to leave the country they
want to stay in Poland because when they
are close to their loved ones who are
still in the Ukraine and so
um it's a little bit like a conflict
um the authorities would like to send
the people further away Europe is
willing to take them but the people
rather stay here and the people that
you've been meeting and talking to there
in chemical what kind of mental and
physical state have they been in when
they arrive in Poland
many people we have been talking to over
the last days are heavily traumatized
because whereas in the first days people
who came here were like had been able to
flee the country before their actual War
reached their neighborhoods but people
who are coming right now they have been
shelves they had been in bunkers for
days then they tried to flee they
couldn't get out some were shot at so
they're heavily traumatized and also
disoriented and really not knowing where
to go and what to do next
just shocking shocking stories Regatta
shulka thanks very much
as Russia expands its offensive in
Ukraine anti-war protesters have
gathered in cities around the world
across Europe thousands have taken to
the streets of Amsterdam Vienna Warsaw
and Florence while a group of Russian
protesters gathered outside the Russian
Embassy in Madrid hundreds more rallied
in the Israeli capital of Tel Aviv
calling on the Russian president to end
the war
there's also a large demonstration
taking place here in Berlin today in
DW's Benjamin Alvarez Gruber is there he
joins me now Benjamin what's going on
down there today what's happening Where
You Are
as you can see behind me people are
still walking they started at the
alexanderplatzkoy a very typical Square
here in Belinda walking towards a
Brandenburg gate calling for the end of
War also is supporting the sanctions by
the German government by G7 by Germany
and asking for tougher sanctions when it
comes to gas and oil imports for Russia
some people are directly also asking for
a no-fly zone and NATO norfly Zone and
they're showing solidarity with the
Ukrainian refugees who are coming to
Berlin into Germany I wanted to ask you
about what the people there attending
the demonstration today are demanding
you've mentioned some things there do
you get a sense that they're generally
in agreement with how the German
government is handling the response or
their or you think that mainly they're
calling for more to be done
they are going for more and they want to
see a stricter uh also a play by the
German government they say when it comes
for example to Imports when it comes to
gas when it comes to oil Germany should
take a stricter um stricter pause also
with the import and they also demanding
more changes when it comes to the
relation that you should take with
Russia that's what the people we've been
speaking to here have told us
sting there's been a huge volunteer
response here in Germany particularly in
Berlin where a lot of people we've seen
all the pictures of people arriving at
Berlin Station tell us a bit about the
aid effort here in the city
that's right it has been incredible
yesterday evening I went to the central
station here in Berlin and a lot of
volunteers are coming 24 7 to the
station wood trains with people with
refugees from Ukraine are arriving
helping them with housing helping them
with food and also helping them when it
comes to translation a lot of them are
coming to Berlin to then continue the
trip to other German cities and it has
been really incredible and it reminds me
of what we saw in 2015 with the Syrian
refugee crisis so a lot of them helping
with accommodation also pledging
additional help for those fleeing Terror
and War right now
DW correspondent Benjamin Alvarez Gruber
will speak to you during the day thanks
very much
[Music]